hey guys I'm Ryan right hi guys I'm
Veronica six steps
Veronica six toes gets disturbed by
these videos oh no what are you watching
raka raka oh my god they feel like they
progressively get more and more gruesome
and violent yeah each time now if they
don't do it I feel like there's gonna be
something missing in it
well it's called supermarket violence
begin
and you said dissipate something or
smarty tell me kick me [ __ ]
my everything
house
who do you think you are okay
very very smart what they did think is
they Pro feel like they're at this point
where they're like okay people are
probably expecting a lot of like blood
and gore now they knew how to not use
blood and gore but still incorporate
their physical violence in a funny way
that was different without resorting to
the gory stuff so the very [ __ ]
impressive how they decided to take that
transition with their next sketch man
first I'd like to say that look like it
was so much fun - everybody is wonders
what it would be like to have you know
food fight through that extreme middle
of a grocery store and second I wonder
what they budget was like because they
had to rent out again yeah and then and
ruin all of these you know products it
seems like their short films and
sketches they're they're getting better
and better development as they progress
you know probably cuz they're getting
more money now isn't that our success
which is great that they're using it to
go back and make better sketches and
have higher quality what I really liked
is I forgot the guys name but the main
rack of Records
they're really good with stunts oh yeah
like that's something I don't hear
people give them enough credit over but
they're great when it comes to stunts oh
yeah it definitely like when you see him
like you know that's the that's the rack
or a good guy he's like flying over [ __ ]
flipping around and stuff like that's
awesome that he's willing they're
willing to commit to that just for the
sake of comedy you know like just go
[ __ ] crazy because these guys I we
had the opportunity to meet them at uh
was it called that [ __ ] place were
pals no it's a VidCon they're [ __ ]
just - suck some fires [ __ ] [ __ ]
annoying ass anyway we got to ask some
questions so [ __ ] annoying babe it's
just it's just like wow if you're like
12 and 13 and you're into some pretty
boy Viner
this is VidCon for you just have to get
that off my chest real fast you guys
want to go to VidCon anyway guys I hope
you invite me back next year be great
them at VidCon and we got to ask them
some questions you see that they're
dudes who are just like having a fun
time blast up there they were like
stealing the mic from each other and
they were totally fine with that
whenever it was stolen from it was just
like banter back and forth at the twins
and they just like it's really cool and
their personality and energy that they
possess some real-life transfers over to
the short films and sketches so well
yeah that type of energy that flare that
spontaneity like I don't feel like these
guys are like let's prepare a whole shot
list and do I feel like there's a
spontaneity to when they're filming that
they get there and they're just coming
up with the next shot as they go along
and stuff that would have been a good
question to ask them because what if it
they are very very meticulous about how
everything goes the other way but it
does seem like they would be more
spontaneous yeah because you feel that
vibe from it I feel like you can tell
when it when something is more like I
don't feel like they have like an
official script I feel like they might
have like an outline or something yeah
that they follow but I don't know about
like a very specific script yeah
probably I write they probably do
probably yeah yeah I mean they're
comedians but they're else the physical
comedy is great well anyway guys thank
you raka raka for providing more
entertainment for us like 22 or
something yeah they're pretty young
would you sleep with them no really why
not I'm not attracted to them they
probably means there's some really nasty
stuff like you something really nasty
stuff to both of them hmm I'd let you do
it I'd let you do it I just have to be
in the room I blog it
Veronica Iraq Iraq I have sex reaction
yeah and then I'll get a boost and
subscribe anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new to it
you can subscribe today and become a
raincheck does your objective reject the
night Munir yo you want do reactions na
want those some reactions oh yes son of
a [ __ ] show you yo danira check out
Veronica's channel where there's blogs
acoustic covers originals and she's
actually in a competition right now that
make me famous calm competition
where you can vote for her she's in the
second round right now and she she needs
your votes so vote for her so she can
win and become super famous so I could
live off her fame and fortune voting
polls open on Thursday this Thursday I
don't know what the date but just check
it out my second matchup and I'll be
performing with originals so do you
wanna have sex no you're annoying no
okay let's just turn off the camera
we're not having sex
yeah what sir you don't have sex I don't
feel like having sex right now my baby's
here not the kid the camera is Oh